Oh out of context this is so weird
I'm Cheska I'm Donnie and today we're
swapping sexy Halloween costumes we've
been married for five years in the eyes
of the law 30 years in the eyes of God
yeah because he had a church wedding I
don't think we've ever done a couples
costume in Halloween and we've known
each other 10 years only because like we
get lazy you know we're like let's dress
up this year and then go over here for
our culture it's Day of the Dead but
like Halloween was never a big thing
growing up I do really want to do a
couples costume this year
I actually very excited because he has
no boundaries and he's never shy I'm an
introvert shy an introvert is different
one time my friend was selling sexy
Laker costume like for women it was like
sighs for women and that he bought it
for himself but he posted an Instagram
photo and then my cousins like you know
messaged me and they were like if
grandma sees this she would be very
confused my grandma is not gonna see
this video unless I show it to her which
I'm not going to I'm excited to see your
your sexy legs sue let's try it on
patron Bella mafia
it's a flashy flapper I don't know what
a flapper is but it looks nice roaring
20s I think this is gonna look super fly
I'm kind of afraid of the fishnets cuz I
don't know I didn't shave for today
fishnet not included so it's fine okay
I'm good then
[Music]
that looks great on you
I'm surprised it fits I'm surprised to
look great it's like two sizes too large
I know I feel like if I was gonna take
this seriously I would maybe go to a
thrift shop and get like my cigar in a
cigar
because this is so sexy I do wish that
this costume was kind of like more
Chippendale ish topless it's and just
like a clip on here and you can see
somebody's like abs and stuff I think
that would be yeah bad no it is way too
big I was trying to hide my underwear so
I don't have underwear lines right here
yeah you need a phone I was not prepared
your butt looks nice oh it reeks this is
so fun I wouldn't go out with this size
I'd totally go home in this it's
comfortable it's cool I just have to be
careful how I sit like this like like
Princess Diaries like this oh this is a
portrait of an American family in the
20s very conservative
I just meal none I've always wanted to
be a nun well I wanted to be a pope Pope
isn't a nun well close enough there's a
pretty good priest costume we're
Catholic hardcore I mean we're we're
Catholic but we're very liberal changes
[Music]
ah
bless me Father for I have sinned
it's fourth but it feels very still very
conservative with the sleeves I mean no
nun would wear no it's above the knee so
it like in nun standards it's sexy in
American standards it's not really that
sexy oh yeah I look great I couldn't
wear this and then if I get a speeding
ticket maybe they won't give me a ticket
I'm definitely not letting my
grandmother watch this why because she's
Catholic she's more Catholic than we are
this is not a sexy priest I feel like a
sexy priest would be like tighter
button-down shirt it would like that
thing but the one thing about this
costume though this is full disclosure I
peed it's so easy to pee you just lift
it up and you just lift it up and just
pee you guys have it good that's the
advantage of skirts Oh deer in
headlights the boobs are the headlights
highroad see oh it's a road it's so like
you know when somebody wears a couples
costume like there's a deer it usually
it's like a deer and a hunter like
you're a guy you're hunting down the
women it's very weird and like
patriarchal but this is kind of cool
because it's like deer in headlights
he's like whoa ladies it's kind of safe
for your grand want to look at yeah I
think she would just laugh with the
boobs yeah she'd just be like boobs big
let's try it do these light up oh nice
fun actual woman wore this you wouldn't
want to be tapping their boobs this is
really short it isn't it is really
shortly favorite if I raise my hands if
you raise your hands you can see
everything but looks nice it is it is it
is really comfortable I like everything
about this costume it's really cute yeah
I love this
yeah his face looks squash did he get
run over that's the point that's oh no
it's sad no I don't want to work I would
like this to be like a non run over non
meth face dear our full body beer yeah
like a full body beer would be cool this
is really comfy
aside from the fact that it's really
short everything else is comfortable the
lights are really cool oh yeah
yeah I think I want more of a costume
for me instead of just a hat oh you
should do that
like a what this pose no that's just
this is a reminder Halloween is around
the corner we should really like think
about this already it's really fun I
mean to be honest it's not the costumes
per se but the idea behind it the
creativity so I like it I think the the
Mafia twenties dude costume was really
cool it was just too loose but as a
couples costume I think this one is the
funnest you know I agree this was
definitely the best idea it's more fun I
kind of bent like the nun one just
because it was really hot is really warm
the twenties one though oh my god when
you when you do that thrill thing yeah
it's almost as fun as a tactile thing
plus once a year during Halloween if I
wear these I can pee without any problem
it's the best feeling ever
I think you a little bit yeah we can
keep it you can ask can we keep it we
can keep it okay cool
if you haven't done a couples costume
for our Halloween just like we did I
think it's the best thing ever once you
do it you figure out oh my god this is
so fun we'll do it okay good
[Music]